what's up everybody this is cyborg
playing cyborg booyah and booyaskadoo
hello this is rafiq hello this is
aqualad
i talk too much as it is sometimes i get
tired of hearing myself
when i come home there's a lot of times
that i can hear
my voice blaring out of that tv and
sometimes i'm like man you got to turn
that dude off
man that's a lot of me
what's up everybody my name is kari
payton i am a voice actor
i have played rafiki from the lion guard
i'd like to do him aqualad who is very
calm
and tries to get everyone to listen his
father
who is angry black manta i also play a
fella named
cyborg booyah boo yaska doo and this is
the rest of my crew over here look at
that the teen
titans boom boom boom
you can't just go around having fun
while the ravens are kidnapped and the
trigons are on the loose with the warlag
i started voice acting about 10 years
into my career i did a lot of theater
a lot of shakespeare commercials and
little movies
teen titans was actually my first voice
over audition the funny thing about
auditioning for cyborg the first time
is that it was literally me just excited
to have an audition
that is the whole mo behind my voice
it's like really
you're gonna let me do this this is
crazy what are you guys doing
what are you guys doing
the hell you doing i was exuberant
and i'm loud and they wanted a nice loud
dude who could stay loud for four hours
at a clip
cyborg is near and dear to my heart
because he's closest to me
i wasn't trying to change my voice i was
just excited
i never in my wildest dreams thought
somebody would let me play rafiki
they do not stop talking it's the one
time i called my mom
to tell her i got a job i was like mom
you're not gonna believe this
and i can only do it for about 15
minutes because it's tiring to play
rafiki he's so
all over the place that by the time i
finish i am exhausted
i just found it kind of like a dance and
you feel the
waves of him moving up and down and the
dynamism of his voice
it is easy after it is hard
outside of my voiceover work i also play
king ezekiel on the walking dead
i am king ezekiel i don't think i would
have been cast
if it wasn't for all of the shakespeare
and experimental black box theater that
i did in my 20s i was just
kind of uniquely qualified to do that
job because he has kind of a
shakespearean vocal quality i provided a
light to lead my people forward through
the darkness
and they have made my fictions realities
and that wasn't a part of the
audition when they asked me to do it i
read it and i was like
no this guy talks a certain way and then
he changes the way that he speaks
depending on the circumstance and so
because i had played with my voice for
so long it was natural to me
welcome to the kingdom one of the
coolest things that ever happened to me
being cyborg is that i was at a
convention once in this big dude this
big burly dude he was like six
four and he slides over this picture of
cyborg and he was like
i gotta tell you this show got me
through a lot of rough times in my life
i just picked my arms up i was like man
come here and this big old dude just
gave me this big old bear
hug and over the last couple of years i
have met so many people
that the stories that i've helped to
tell have been
integral in their life just keeping them
going keeping them
moving in the right direction that's all
i've ever really wanted
i'm living the dream i guess call cyborg
he can't shoot a rocket from his shoes
you